rawrr are you a perfectionist and if so
how do you let go of your film baby yeah
I guess I'm not perfect mist but I also
just can't wait to show the movie to an
audience so I think that's what it gets
me going to the final steps is just a
joy really getting to see it with an
audience and you graduated from film
school in 2002 and now you're here it's
2015 you're up for an Academy Award for
a foreign language film Norwegian yeah
weird uh no reason contender for that
yeah do you think that you could have
gotten to this point without film school
I know you've been making film since
eighth grade yeah but do you really feel
that film school helped you get here
yeah at least it gave me the chance to
work with people and to experiment and
and yeah it gives you a lot of knowledge
and and the chance to work with people
yeah right
but it seemed like you were making films
before even so much of the technology's
changed now and you'd learn the craft
and the eye for it yeah do you feel that
you still could have developed this
without really going to film school yeah
some of it probably and so yeah I think
the best thing about film school is the
people you meet and the connections you
make and
and that you have all this equipment
available so you're sure we get the
chance to try out stuff and and that's I
think what you learn a lot from when you
look at a character when you break it
down do you see how much is this
character like me is to eaten in the
film and how much am I very dissimilar
what do you not look at it I don't think
so much about myself actually because
it's a pretty easy you can find and if I
find anything I mean any human being or
Alice but that was part there lie
because of course as anything when it
comes to acting yes and no because it's
a I definitely feel which sides of me
that are strong in this character yeah I
do that and I often you feel that quite
instantly and it's an intuition you just
yeah you just know it and then it's also
fun I like thinking about it a bit too
and sometimes making up a story or
sometimes not just shooting from the hip
you know and starting yeah the way
you've delved into a character has it
changed over the years or is it pretty
much the same it's changed some because
earlier on I was more into making up I
did this even more making up story my
stories were more detailed when I was
because because I know that can directly
infect my work but now some sometimes I
I don't do it that that thorough anymore
often because it's my intuition is
strong and I've the inner life I was
thinking more about the inner life
earlier on than I am now that comes yeah
just comes
but the what's hard about what I'm might
find the hardest part is actually having
a job when you're an actor that your
role my the person I'm portraying has a
job that's difficult because that's
physical and it's something that I will
need to find out about and learn about
because it's not human relations and
emotions and yeah or if there are some
very specific I following it very
specific things in this person's life
that's changed her or that has meant a
lot to her then I wouldn't need to maybe
to do researched on that but just for
were normal people I'd say it's comes
quickly quicker now so the wave is a
Hollywood eyes diversion of a Norwegian
disaster film what is the difference
between a Norwegian or Scandinavian film
versus the Hollywood movies in your
opinion I would rather say that it's a
Norwegian life every taken the disaster
genre but then tried to ground it in a
Norwegian reality to also take that do
what I guess European film is more known
for like having characters that you take
your time and getting to know and that
you go a little bit deeper in to the
psychology of the characters and I guess
that's what we tried with this movie as
well and to so that the disaster when
that happens has as much of an emotional
impact as possible for acting Norwegian
acting in terms of the style
maybe the method versus what you see in
American film or television what do you
see is the difference or maybe there's
very little difference
I wouldn't know really but it's always a
question of
and genre whatever you're doing and
finding the specific tone and I remember
one particular event during shooting was
because no one really knows this Ron and
he loves it and he's seen so many films
of this genre his heart lives there and
I remember he said to me oh no when
you're leaving that room when you made
that phone call just a little smile yes
of course that's how you're that's how
you do it in this particular universe so
it's it's a question of tone and more
than Norwegian or American I think I
don't know but yeah I think so how was
the role of Eden offered to you how did
you find out about it uh-huh I went to
audition and then they called me the day
after said do you want it which is nice
because often is like oh you know it's
hard it's minimal but not this time no I
think when I saw online Christopher
together I really felt that we had found
our couple for the movie if you were to
be offered a million dollars or the
chance to act for free in your favorite
American television show what would you
choose the favorite show or the million
yeah and that's a no-brainer
yeah it would be the favorite
okay and what show would that be oh my
god it would be one of those yeah well
it would have been six feet under if it
still existed or it would be homeland or
it would be a house of cards or it would
be you know all of those all of those
you can live the list goes on
yeah okay thank you I have it yeah yeah
thank you yeah